with the president's approval ratings
below 40 percent democrats are hoping
that the bill can help improve their
chances in the upcoming midterm
elections and we find ed o'keefe at the
white house for us once again ed on
paper it would seem like a good week
last week for the president and the
start of another good one this week but
the numbers don't suggest so much good
morning good morning tony welcome back
for vacation good to see you and while
democrats didn't get everything they
wanted no matter how you slice it this
has been one of the most successful
stretches of the biden presidency in
addition to the health and climate bill
expected to be passed later this week
consider all the other things that
they've gotten done there was a passage
of major legislation boosting the
nation's high-tech manufacturing sector
and a plan to provide federal aid to
military veterans exposed to burn pits
and other toxins both of which the
president plans to sign this week those
follow passage this summer of a major
gun control and mental health bill and
internationally there's the senate
approval of a plan to let finland and
sweden join nato as well as the
successful killing of al-qaeda's leader
iowan al-zawahiri cbs news has learned
that on the legislation senior aides
have had more direct interaction with
lawmakers on key details of the bill
than president biden has climate change
and health bill has been the focus of
really intense work here at the white
house especially in the last 10 days or
so but the president had no direct
interaction with senator joe manchin
that key senate broker until this past
weekend when he also spoke to about a
dozen other senators to ensure final
passage polls won't give us a sense of
whether this worked or not until about
labor day and remember the top concern
for voters remains the economy and
inflation none of this legislation
provides any immediate relief for that
nate
ed thank you